I think we better do well yeah yeah it's
gonna be great
you don't think you're gonna do it
definitely could be her I'm gonna
reserve judgment it kind of feels like
her skin it kind of feels like her nose
and her chin for sure I'm gonna say
maybe but I'm holding reservation I'm
not saying yes or no
[Music]
I think this one's her I said the last
one had her skin kind of cut the same
but I think this one your chin feels
more like I remember her skin just feels
a little bit more familiar I feel like
that the chin and the nose are they
giveaways and this feels like her again
I'm holding off reservation - oh the
last one I don't want to dig myself a
hole and then like totally be like this
is her and then it could be completely
completely wrong because it would be
like they all feel like her and then
it's gonna be like shot in the dark and
then I'm gonna um I'm gonna lose a
girlfriend holy crap I didn't know the
skin could all feel the same oh yeah all
right I don't think this one's her you
like the chin is too different yeah this
isn't her I dunno this is not her I'm
gonna go I'm gonna say too
oh you're so nervous you really thought
you might go to wrong it's possible
victory is mine yeah we don't have to
break up but you did it yeah yeah see
that's terrible
[Music]